[Musique]
j'avais prévu de faire quelque chose
cette semaine et et vous me donnez
l'occasion de le faire ce soir c'est ma
dernière émission de tpm mais non mais
non mais sérieux et pmp définitivement
je suis là depuis le début j'ai passé
des jours absolument absolument géniaux
j'ai connu des trucs incroyables puisque
j'ai été jusque là scène de l'olympia
grâce à jean luc lemoine
on a fait la millième la semaine
dernière et vraiment je me suis dit que
j'avais joué pas avoir beaucoup mieux
que ce que j'avais fait je pense
qu'aujourd'hui c'est le moment d'arrêter
alors vous étiez pas du tout au courant
je lis ce n'était au courant dans
l'équipe je l'avais dit à personne mais
j'avais prévu de partir un soir de cette
semaine en direct et donc je vais le
faire ce soir puisque vous m'en donnez
l'occasion est donc ce soir ça m'a sera
ma dernière émission et je vais partir
et je vous remercie de tout le bonheur
que vous voulez vous m'avez donné autour
de cette table alors alors je vous
embrasse très et croyez moi alors
[Applaudissements]
noah il est revenu je voudrais dire
juste une chose parce qu'on parle de
mercato je pars pas pour faire autre
chose mais pour moi la télé c'était un
accident très heureux accident mais ma
vie c'était télé 7 jours et ça restera à
télé 7 jours et donc je suis ravi ce
soir de vous dire au revoir et je
voulais je vous aime
oui il reste pas du tout normal après
que je le sais que je pas du tout qu'on
était grave lors des ces drames a pas 10
parce que je suis pas du tout content
j'ai tout je sais que vous n'êtes pas ou
quoi c'est vous et non je m'en vais
voilà c'est terminé je veux pas partir
comme ça non mais c'est vrai je vous dis
je vous embrasse très très fort et leur
métier rêvé de retourner la fin des
missions vous n'avez pas partir
moyennant prévu de le faire de toute
façon par dont la caméra les où j'avais
prévu mais en vérité la terrible et donc
je vous dis mais asseyez-vous des moules
et je mens non mais vraiment j'avais
prévu de le faire donc je vous aime et
vous donnez nous des je vous remercie
vraiment de tout ce que vous avez
je ne sais pas pourquoi c'est pas du
tout pas si c'est une bonne ou pas
est-ce que c'est toi tu vas pas de pot
de départ
mais chez je vous jure je suis pas du
tout pour
alors à part ça ils nous aiment pas vous
dis non je suis pas du tout au courant
de l'histoire
je vous le dis on va voir ce qu'ont
pensé les tweets hausse en tout cas
regardez oui oui une volte thierry reste
à 63% et non à 37% donc les
téléspectateurs veulent que thierry
mauron reste on va faire la lumière sur
cette affaire mais c'est vrai quoi là on
sait pas si c'est une blague de les flip
ou pas ils en sont ils en sont voilà ils
en sont capables dans l'équipe ou bien
est ce que c'est vrai de la part de ça
c'est un peu longues heures on en sera
un petit peu plus bien sûr dans les
prochaines minutes
est ce que quelqu'un tout court ici
autodata a trait au courant non ne t'es
pas au courant mais c'est vrai moi j'dis
pas alors mathieu note n'était pas au
courant qu'il allait faire une sortie si
oui comme aussi les théâtrales voilà riz
en revanche jeu j'avais senti j'avais
entendu quelques échos qui voulait il
voulait vraiment s'en aller et qui voit
là que c'était sa dernière année il faut
que s'est pas précipité
écoutez en tout cas thierry on va votre
batteur revenir demain pour qui on note
des explications là dessus parce que je
n'ai pas vu donc je vais le voir après
l'émission j'étais pas du tout au
courant et c'est vrai que voilà ils font
ce qu'ils veulent et voilà thiery fait
ce qu'il veut moi ça j'aurais aimé qu'il
reste avec nous parce que j'aime
beaucoup mais en tout cas voilà il nous
a dit voilà ce qu'ils pensaient thierry
moreau en tout cas on lui fait de gros
bisous et j'irai le voir après et bien
sûr on aura des explications demain
parce que thierry c'est vrai que c'est
quand même la famille et c'est vrai
qu'on n'a pas donné vraiment
d'explication jean-michel je vous sens
j'ai bout du rouleau
ah bah oui parce que j'en plaisante et
juste avant elle écrivait ce que je veux
c'est une chronique on en fait souvent
et je lui dis ici les gens me tu parles
tu pars tout de suite et comme moi comme
ça où on fait une angine si tu donnes
paraît juste après par de masse la venue
sur le presque terminé second de partir
maintenant et il rigolé comme ça chez
intel milieu d'imagés ainsi qu'il est le
fils d une belle anecdote à la baisse
annoncée pour dire que on est coupé en à
l'ouest on savait tous que j'irai le
voir tout à l'heure thierry moreau
j'espère qui m'attendra et on aura tous
les sens on aurait toutes les
explications de mme al shihri chansons
rétro plaisir pour que soient les gens
parlent pas qu'on peut pas parler prénom
et nom